Ukraine is unraveling fast torn apart by
war with thousands fleeing politics here
is changing the economy is faltering but
underlying all of this is a forgotten
epidemic and Sky News has been to the
heart of it
as they compete with you they can cut
you half a million people are living
with HIV or AIDS in Ukraine it is one of
the fastest growing epidemics in the
world but the government here is
struggling to fund vital drugs
antiretrovirals used to prevent the
virus spreading from mother to child
this young boy will need antiretroviral
drugs like we need air to breathe there
is potential for a real disaster
definitely I feel that I am NOT in
Ukraine I determine Africa somewhere and
we enter the extraordinary underground
world of those who've grown up with AIDS
and HIV and ask what's installed for
today's children of the epidemic
Ukraine has had a problem with HIV and
AIDS ever since it gained independence
from the Soviet Union in 1991 until last
year it had made progress on cutting
down on one of the key indicators the
transfer of the virus from mother to
child but Ukraine has been in crisis for
nearly a year now and that rate is
beginning to rise again
the budget probably today is not really
enough to fulfill all the needs I would
say that the impact of the specific
crisis is also enabling to bring to the
surface a lot of the weaknesses the
problem is the cost of these drugs which
I used to prevent or suppress the spread
of HIV they called anti retrovirals the
system is breaking down on one end and
secondly you know the there is a
shortage of anti retrovirals that's
that's definitely the case the cost one
because they cost money they are
expensive the the international
community is there to support but you
know probably not enough to fulfil you
know all the limits so children are
being born with HIV when they should
never have been born
that strength it doesn't get any bigger
for crisis than that does it absolutely
because we have but there is potential
for a real disaster there is one place
in Ukraine where children with AIDS can
be treated
where they feel protected from the huge
stigma that still exists here
what we've been invited to visit a
hospital here in Kiev which specifically
treats children who are HIV positive
many of whom contracted the virus from
their mothers and you know the truth is
we've got no idea what it's going to be
like inside until we get there the Aqua
debt clinic is the only one of its kind
in Ukraine and this is the first time
that cameras have been allowed inside it
treats children with HIV and
tuberculosis the other major epidemic
you to save money they switch off the
lights and turn down the heating even
though it's - - outside
so we take all severe cases all
difficult cases from of Ukraine usually
here we have a confection HIV MTB in 80%
probably now in our hospital children
have a TV when doctors oncologist and
hematologist see HIV status they are
very frightened and they always big
pleasure leaves these children in our
Hospital so there is room for 20
children here and it's folk the failure
to prevent the virus from spreading to
children is laid bare here for those who
have no parents it can be as good as it
gets
these are just two of the children here
in this hospital this is Ross dam who is
five months old he was born hiv-positive
antiretrovirals too late to prevent the
transfer of this virus he is destined
for a life in an orphanage and this is
Sascha who is three years old he has a
drug-resistant tuberculosis as well as
full-blown AIDS and in the coming weeks
he will end up in an orphanage an
orphanage in Ukraine is a life of
uncertainty and this young boy will need
antiretroviral drugs like we need air to
breathe it will be for life the problem
for children like Sasha and Rustom is
the government is running out of money
and is desperate to make savings first
of all it's very expensive treatment and
our government prefer to economic to
save money and buy cheaper cheaper
treatment cheaper drugs the Indian or
any other production but not very good
quality Dima has
ADEs but his parents don't his mother
says she has no idea how he contracted
it they do know is that his late
grandfather was HIV positive just not
good anymore by oh sweet you know what
it's um
he is singing that book Toto's not does
that to somebody don't know it's not
like influences it it's going in air and
you can just catch it from air we
explained the way of transmission of HIV
we explained everything but still we
have a higher level of stigma the
Ministry of Health in Kiev six months of
political turmoil have shaken Ukraine's
finances the government has been forced
to sign a seventeen billion dollar
bailout with the International Monetary
Fund that means there's less money to
spend on health this is also the new
home for a new Health Minister just a
month in the job this is Alexandra vataj
Vili and he says on the whole Ukraine is
coping we are we're very well prepared
to face these challenges
and again to to send clear messages with
assistance to the international donors
what are you seeing here what's your
message are you happy with the way you
create its handling its hiv/aids
epidemic were you sitting here telling
me you happy with given the situation in
the country overall situation given the
full-blown Russian aggression war they
were facing given the financial crisis
given a total of mismanagement of the
country by the previous government for
three to four years yes
given all that we are at least having a
grip on the situation with HIV
but when presented with the figures that
there's actually been a rise in the rate
of transferal from mother to baby the
minister is not so sure so it takes
advice okay so there's an Inc continue
yeah okay there was an increase in 2013
compared to 2012 by 1% we're getting
data for 2014 now obviously that needs
to be taken care of whether if it
requires more money or or or redirecting
or spending money more effective
effectively through effective programs
that's another another another issue so
we have to look at that on why did we
have this increase in 2013
sasha wanders the hospital calling for
his mother but she abandoned him a year
ago so what are his prospects what could
life have in store for him we will the
children who were born today be in ten
years time
unfortunately nowhere meaning there is a
serious list risk to you know to go
towards a lost you know generation
definitely you are angry frightened
scared frustrated all of these things
because I don't know how to help in what
to do in this situation with the number
of children you know born to HIV
increasing and very limited chances to
actually ensure proper care and proper
treatment for them this is a Desa in the
south where the first case of AIDS
entered Ukraine in 1987
and we've come here to meet the lost
children of this epidemic now older and
in poor health
they are the Forgotten casualties of
Ukraine's AIDS war two year old boy
lives here and many have HIV or
full-blown AIDS it is an underground
home for an underground life
in the spring of 1987 a 22 year old man
became the first person to be diagnosed
as HIV positive in Ukraine here in the
southern Black Sea port of Odessa
it was the beginning of an epidemic that
still has a tight grip here once a
thriving town it was known as the Soviet
Chicago today it's rundown and depressed
Desa also has the highest concentration
of AIDS and HIV anywhere in Europe many
have no choice but to live in the
shadows we've come here to find out how
life has turned out for some of the
children who've grown up with AIDS in
Ukraine what age have you been on the
streets he since the age of nine
my age of 10 they need help and they get
it from time to time
on a cold night like this hot food bread
and something warm to drink is welcome
they have no family or parents
this is vulva is 22 and he's had AIDS
since he was 14 we find him being
treated by an outreach nurse on the
streets he injects chemicals like paint
thinner and ethanol but what he really
needs is anti retrovirals and if he
doesn't get them he'll die
the nurse is asked to go into a
makeshift hostel to treat another man
Vladimir Koval look at charity worker
agrees to take us inside what's the risk
of going in here if you will not under
their roof they will start to be very
aggressive
because of the high levels of
tuberculosis here we're all told to wear
masks
the chemical drugs the man's been on
combined with his AIDS is having a
terrible impact on his body he's in the
corner on a bed and when he peels away a
bandage it reveals a huge sore three of
his toes have literally dropped off the
chemical drugs have eaten through the
muscle the nurse is now in there healing
it I've seen anything like that ever the
smell was acrid there was crates of beer
everywhere and the conditions were
horrendous and that is how they live in
there there is very little help for
people with HIV and AIDS in towns like
adesso charities take the strain where
the government fails to help access to
medical care education and housing are a
huge problem for people living with AIDS
and so many have to live wherever they
can we've been told about a family who
live underground
they all have AIDS apart from one of a
two-year-old boy but to get to them we
have to go down into a basement and then
through a labyrinth of hot water pipes
that feeds the building's above you can
smell the cat urine everywhere there are
clothes under you can feel the warmth
coming off the pipes and up above the
streets of Edessa
just go on and down there the man tells
me that's that's the toilet down there
the first person we see is Misha a
toddler his mother only contracted HIV
after he was born
she's a sex worker by night and she's
left him with his auntie there are four
separate families living down here most
grew up in Ukraine's crowded orphanages
some were born with AIDS some contracted
it growing up Lena grew up on the street
injected chemicals and ended up in
prison this strange subterranean world
is home how easy is it to access drugs a
antiretrovirals and things like this
bleak existence provides an insight into
the kind of world today's children with
AIDS may have in store for them we say
goodbye to the families and make our way
back up to the surface until recently
children with AIDS and HIV founded
almost impossible to go to nursery or
school some parents were too worried
that their children might catch the
virus somehow
but there are places where children can
go this charity in Edessa
helps youngsters deal with their HIV or
AIDS
Rustem a Sanath was once a street child
living with HIV here in a desert as a
drug addict he stole from shops to feed
himself now he works at the charity
helping the children I asked brush stem
what he thinks the prospects are for
children like Sasha the boy we met in
the Children's Hospital in Kiev a new
option with Arsenal Sofia renu-it no bro
no but she so wishes for the new
purchase number on back in Kiev
campaigners are urging the new
government here to put more money into
the AIDS program the Global Fund for
fighting AIDS continues to support
Ukraine but there are no guarantees for
the future health issue is now
especially HIV issue is not a priority
for for the government Pavlo scarlet
campaigns on behalf of people with HIV
and AIDS what effect is the crisis in
Ukraine having on do you think the
government's ability to maintain some
kind of hiv/aids program so most of the
budget is going to the defense to law
enforcement and all activities most
activities related to to this crisis in
the East in Crimea so all of the work
that's gone on in Ukraine over the last
few years could begin to address it
might be a disaster the funds that are
committed by the government are
appropriately
to cover all the gaps the assistance of
international donors including the
Global Fund which recently approved
hundred thirty three million dollar
three-year project assisting HIV and TB
are there so the government you don't
need to put any more funds into the
fighting of HIV if we need to put more
funds we have an open doors with UNICEF
with Global Fund and others to go back
to them with your money not not external
funding not funding from UNICEF are you
saying that as a government you're not
committing any more public funds from
the public budget to the fight against
HIV and AIDS because that's what they
say is necessary the government has
committed money that the government
could spare don't act today if we don't
accelerate efforts if we don't support
as it is needed definitely we are going
to see the this epidemics you know
growing even in even faster I understand
that we need to change this system but
I'm afraid the people who are on the job
they don't understand in which way it
should be changed and they're very far
from people say real situations that
they cannot get any additional money
from the state budget because it's
almost empty
he doesn't know it yet but baby rush
stem faces huge challenges in his life
the stigma of having AIDS and the perils
of having the state as a parent he could
get a good orphanage it's possible he
could get a bad one
it is the lottery of his life
sasha is spending his first nights in a
Ukrainian orphanage his future like so
many others is unknown doctors say if he
received the right drugs at the right
time his life could have been so very
different
you